let's start with the big
and the basic question what is a
blockchain
and why is it interesting why is it
fascinating why is it powerful
all right so a blockchain think of it is
a
is really a common database distributed
think about is a ledger
in which everybody can write an entry in
a page
you can write i can write and everybody
can read
and you have a guarantee that everybody
has the same copy of the ledger
that is in front of you so if whatever
you see on page seven
anyone else is on page seven
so what is uh extraordinary about this
is this a common knowledge thing that i
think is a really
a first for humanity i mean if you look
at communication
like right now you can communicate very
quickly
images or thoughts or photos but do you
have a very
certainty that whatever you have
received has been received by everybody
else
and not really and so this is a
commonality of your knowledge
and the certainty that everybody can
write nobody
has been prevented for having whatever
they want nobody can erase
nobody can tear a page of a ledger
nobody can swap page
nobody can change anything and that is a
immutable comma record
is extremely powerful and uh there's
something fundamental that is
decentralized about it so at least in
spirit
uh some degree against maybe a
resistance to centralization
absolutely if it is not decentralized
how can it be common knowledge if only
one person or a few people at the ledger
the only you don't have villager you
have to ask you know what is on page
seven
and how do you know that whatever they
tell you is on page seven
they tell the same thing to everybody
else and so
that is this commandant is extremely
powerful just uh um just to give you an
example a sumo beta you do an auction
okay
you have a work very hard you build a
building
and now you want to auction off makes
sense because
uh you want to auction worldwide better
yet you want to tokenize the building
and sell it and all in parcels
now everybody sees the bids
and you know that everybody sees the
bids you and i see the same and so
does everybody else
so you know that the fair price has
reached and you know
who owns what and who has paid how much
and if you do it in stock instead of
advising on a centralized system
i put a bid say oh congratulations alex
you won
and your price is twelve thousand five
hundred and seventy
how do you know so if instead there is a
common knowledge is a very powerful uh
tool for humanity
you